la sphère des sans papiers de l'église
saint-bernard avait occupé la une de
l'actualité c'était au mois d'août
dernier avec l'arrivée de la gauche au
pouvoir
ces sans-papiers espère bien obtenir
satisfaction une marche symbolique les
amènera demain devant l'hôtel matignon
où ils souhaitent être reçus par le
premier ministre maryse burgot bernard
puissance aux amateurs
qui fit in le sien jeudi dans le coma
qui proposait mais j'ai gardé ce trader
450 km dans les basques ils sont partis
lundi d'angoulême et à raison de 50
kilomètres par jour
ils seront demain à paris à matinée une
marche symbolique des sans papiers pour
se rappeler au bon souvenir de monsieur
jospin et du nouveau gouvernement
ça poussera pour moi ça pied ça montrait
qu'on a montré qu'on est là voilà on est
là on n'a pas le papier on a une visite
pause déjeuner loin du vacarme de la
nationale ans ambiance plutôt détendue
ces hommes et ces femmes n'ont pas
oublié que lionel jospin a promis
l'abrogation des lois pasqua debré alors
pour l'instant ils sont plutôt confiants
et leur nouveau nouvel obs d'arrivée
jean pierre chevènement qui a toujours
dit qu'il était favorable à la
régularisation des sans papiers
on ne voit pas pourquoi aujourd'hui on
indique ce soir à matignon qu'une
délégation sera reçue demain dans la
journée et services du premier ministre
confirme aussi qu'une nouvelle
législation est envisagé ont remplacé
les lois pasqua debré législation qui
s'appuiera entre autres sur ce document
un avis émis par la commission nationale
consultative des droits de l'homme et
qui fixe des critères pour la
régularisation des sans-papiers
locuteurs sont des critères simples
fondé sur les principes fondamentaux des
droits de l'homme comme par exemple le
droit de vivre en famille le
gouvernement pourrait donc retenir les
six critères proposés par cette
commission
ceux qui votent évidemment dire que tous
les sans papiers ne serez pas
régularisée